Josh, you've been homeschooled
your whole life.
So public school
is going to be challenging.
Here we go.
Oh, uh, guys...
If the leg is the first thing
kids know about me,
that's all they'll care about.
I wanna make friends because they like me,
not because they feel bad for me.
Just take my advice.
Lay low for a little while.
What's homeschool like?
It's basically a vanilla-scented prison.
He's a legend.
There's so much to do.
I mean, so much to try.
I don't wanna miss any of it.
Do you want to sneak soda into a movie?
-How'd it go?
-It was good.
Mostly good.
Let me tell your mom about this.
We just gotta find the right time.
Ooh, secrets.
Things are changing.
There is no going back.
You've always inspired me
to never back down from a challenge.
If you don't diversify
your extra-curriculars early,
you're toast.
-Josh Dubin.
-Here.
Here.
Here!